ils sont quelques dizaines de livreurs à
avoir répondu à l'invitation du clap
le collectif des livreurs autonome des
plateformes rassemblement pour dire non
au racisme pour protester contre les
discriminations donc ils peuvent être
parfois victimes rassemblement qui fait
écho aux dernières agressions qui ont eu
lieu récemment en france notamment celle
du côté de laval avec ce message un cas
reçu un livreur de la part d'une cliente
dépêche-toi esclaves autre affaire qui a
également fait le tour des réseaux
sociaux cette agression d'un livreur du
côté de cergy pontoise il a été insulté
et roué de coups voilà c'était
l'objectif principal de ce rassemblement
aujourd'hui protester contre
l'augmentation des agressions contre les
livres à c'est pas parce que les
livreurs sont mal payés c'est pas parce
que beaucoup sont noirs qu'il faut les
insultes et les traités d'esclaves ça
ramène à des choses qui sont très très
douloureuses notamment pour ces gens là
et il faut que les clients les
restaurateurs tous les citoyens se
rendent compte de la dudh du mépris du
mépris et surtout du danger qu'il ya à
faire revenir ce genre de propos dans le
paysage français
puis là il ya trois actes qui ont été
médiatisés mais c'est des dizaines et
des centaines tous les jours de clients
qui se laisse aller de restaurants qui
méprisent de même des fois dans des
grandes enseignes de fast food les
équipiers sont complètement méprisant
vis-à-vis de ces gens là wen aux colères
on invite tous les jours des
discriminations y en a tous les jours
mais ont fini par banaliser parce que et
en a autant aujourd'hui c'est pas dire
est ce pas dire est qu'il ya des gestes
il ya des manières de dire de manier de
fait qu'on se sent frustré on le vit on
le vit tous les jours quotidien que ce
soit envers les restaurateurs que ce
soit anvers est un client mais les
clients vous avez vous allez quoi vous
avez moins d'un pouce en voilà surtout
des restaurateurs et des riverains ne
pas respecter deux fois par des clients
sur la part des clients
pas de connaissances aussi tu vois je
les clients de fois une chute il ya des
morts asus qui sort de la bouche tu vois
mais des fois aussi c'est qu'on va très
mal avec nous mêmes quand quand on les
livre souvent ils sont des trucs
vraiment qu'ils sont nés trop ans pour
ses livreurs qui appelle les plateformes
pour lesquels ils travaillent à prendre
davantage de dispositions pour assurer
leur sécurité
hubert it's a par exemple annoncé la
mise en place d'un bouton
anti-discrimination donnant accès à une
prise en charge prioriser une mesure qui
devrait être effective d'ici à la fin de
l'été alors en dehors du volet et
discrimination ans et livreurs
manifestèrent aussi pour défendre leurs
revendications historiques liées
notamment à leur condition travailler
pour demander la requalification de leur
contrat en salariat